president Trump's newest initiative for
his first hundred days is a tax cut with
big goals and very few specifics the
Trump blueprint would slash tax rates
and eliminate some deductions it doubles
the standard deduction that most
taxpayers take it would also eliminate
taxes that are overwhelmingly paid by
high-income Americans the president's
Treasury secretary and economic advisors
say the tax cuts will pay for themselves
by growing the economy other analysts
say they'll explode the national debt
now this proposal is just one page long
and contains very few details
fischels are saying almost nothing about
who will benefit the most Margaret
Brennan is at the White House with the
plan that's months away from a vote
Margaret good morning good morning well
the US has the highest corporate tax
rate in the world and the biggest cuts
in the president's plan go to large
companies and businesses like his own
but it remains unclear how the
administration will pay for a plan
estimated to reduce tax revenue by seven
trillion over a decade President Trump
said his tax blueprint will unleash
economic growth we will have a massive
tax cut for businesses Treasury
Secretary Stephen minuchin argued that
slashing the corporate tax rate from 35%
down to 15% will give businesses extra
cash to hire and spend this is not just
about large corporations small and
medium-sized businesses will be eligible
for the business rate as well that may
help bring investment back to the US
according to Maya McGinnis of the
nonpartisan committee for a responsible
federal budget this is a very aggressive
very significant corporate tax rate cut
and I think it would have huge effects
on our competitiveness Senate Minority
Leader Chuck Schumer dismissed it as a
giveaway to the wealthy they don't need
another huge tax break while
middle-class Americans and those
struggling to get there need help just
staying afloat details are expected by
August and White House economic advisor
Gary Cohen could not yet say how much of
a tax break lower and middle-class
Americans will get we will let
you know these specific details at the
appropriate moment the goal is to
simplify the tax code by whittling down
the seven personal income tax brackets
to three with rates of 10 25 and 35%
wealthy Americans like the President
himself will benefit from eliminating
the alternative minimum tax as well as
the estate tax Ivanka Trump assured
reporters Tuesday that families will
also receive tax credits for child and
adult day care just how the
administration will make up for all of
the lost revenue without adding to the
nearly 20 trillion dollar debt is
unclear that hard work may now be up to
Congress the opening bid sounds to me
like they hope that somebody will
Ratchet it back and make it fiscally
responsible and just yesterday after
floating that idea of a 24 percent duty
on Canadian lumber a White House
official publicly floated the idea that
the president was considering
withdrawing from the North American Free
Trade Agreement and then immediately hit
the financial markets hours later in a
phone call with the leaders of Mexico
and Canada mr. Trump reassured them that
he was not going to do that at this
point and instead Charlie he plans to
renegotiate NAFTA something Congress has
not yet given him the authority to do
market thanks